my name is Megan Showalter I'm a
Hillsdale College junior majoring
politics and classical studies I'm
currently interning with the Laura
Ingraham show as part of the Washington
Hillsdale internship program Larry P
Arne is the 12th president of Hillsdale
College he received his BA in 1974 from
Arkansas State University graduating
with the highest distinction
he received his MA in government in 1976
and his PhD in government in 1985 from
the Claremont Graduate School he also
studied in England from 1977 to 1980
first as a research student in
international history at the London
School of Economics and then in modern
history at Oxford University while in
England he also served as director of
research for Sir Martin Gilbert the
official biographer of Winston Churchill
from 1985 to 2000 he served as president
of the Claremont Institute while at
Claremont he was the founding chairman
of the California Civil Rights
initiative which was passed by
California voters in 1996 and prohibited
racial preferences in state hiring
contracting and admissions dr. Arnn is
on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the hit the Henry
Salvatori Center of Claremont McKenna
College and the Claremont Institute dr.
Arnn is currently heading the hill
psychologist founders campaign for
capital and endowment goals that will
expand the school's buildings and
grounds strengthen its liberal arts
programs and establish the Hillsdale
Graduate School statesmanship dr. Arnn
is also professor of halt fit politics
and history at Hillsdale where he
teaches courses in Aristotle Winston
Churchill and the American Constitution
please join me in welcoming dr. Larry
Arn who is speaking on the topic how our
economic Liberty can be restored
Thank You Megan I thought Paul Marino
did a splendid job in his remarks and I
thought Britney Baldwin did a better job
introducing him so I'm gonna try to be
as approximately as good as Megan as
Paul achieved with Brittany and then
I'll be okay thank you for watching
those of you who are watching and thank
all of you for being here I see my old
friend Michael pack in the audience I've
seen well how you doing Michael so thank
you David Bob - I and staff here at the
Kirby Center they work really hard and
it's always a joy to come here and I'm
in the college business so I come here
three days a month and it keeps me from
being ruined by the city but they seem
to be relatively immune so far good guys
I'm supposed to tell you how to restore
our economic freedom and I'm gonna do
that by two techniques I'm going to make
you more frightened and then urgent
understanding will lead to some
improvement I hope and then the second
thing is I'm gonna tell one little quick
story about how such a thing was done
one time because I happen to observed it
and paid a little attention to it the
the frightening part depends on an
understanding from the founding that
will help make sense of what's going on
today and some of the things I'm gonna
explain I'll explain them quickly
because they've been well explained by
Paul and by congressman pence - - who
might give my greetings
you know economics is a word that's
almost never mentioned in the American
Revolution it comes up a few times but
it's not really quite what they talk
about they do talk about it in one very
grand place and I'll mention that place
it's really grand in the first inaugural
of George Washington he says that our
Republic is founded I'm talking from
memory but it's close to this in the
great fact in the whole course and
economy of nature the indissoluble union
between virtue and happiness you got to
be good to be happy and the Republic he
goes on to say it's got to be good to be
prosperous and free that word economy
there right that means the general
working of things and I'll tell you how
that word comes up because it's a really
neat word the word economy
from two greek words one of his IKOS
which means house and the other is Nomos
which means law and so economics means
the law of the house the law of
household management the first book of
economics is written by Xenophon it's a
dialogue is called the ergonomic us and
it's about household management it's
actually more philosophic than that the
joke in the middle of that book happens
to be that the man talks on and on about
how his wife does everything he says and
his interlocutor keeps proving that his
wife is probably a lot smarter than he
is and he's really doing what she says a
phenomenon well known in the iron
household so you can see if it's the law
that of the way a house is run it could
be a law of the way everything is run in
the way George Washington uses that word
economics is both local and tight and
grand and cosmic even and economics in
America is we use the term today that's
dominated when they talk about it in the
American Revolution by another
expression and that expression is
property rights you can't read anything
in the American Revolution without
running into that word that term it's
everywhere and the reason it's
everywhere is that it combines two
things and the two things describe the
whole human being body and soul the
first one is the material goods we own
the stuff we have and that stuff we have
is very important to us and the reason
is if I were to go too long I won't
because somebody will jerk the
microphone out of the way for me but if
I were and weak and I talked on for an
hour to everybody get really tired and
there's some Hillsdale College students
here and you guys will probably like
them they will listen politely till the
last Trump soundeth but their bodies
would soon weaken on the other hand too
you can't do it all day long you got to
give a drink and you got to eat
something and you got to sleep every day
and you'll die if you don't do it and
that means that you got to work and that
means that the work that you have to do
you're entitled to the fruit of it it is
your subsist
and your material property comes from
that and remember about human beings
that there's this weird thing about them
that they like everything I just
explained to you
we're the only beings on earth that can
know that all that stuff but on the
other hand we still live just like the
animals in that respect and although we
have reached the state in society where
we store up a lot extra on the other
hand every time the attorney economy
turns down or every time somebody habits
get bad and they don't work or every
time somebody has a terrible misfortune
they suffer and they suffer economically
and their problems so it is our business
as human beings to go about the business
of solving that problem and we have to
do that all the time and we do do it all
the time
and so you have a right to it
because by the way you know it would be
easier like our College it's expensive
to run a college these kids they have
you know every time we have 10 students
we have one teacher and these kids have
to live and they have to eat and their
parents have to help support them and
the college has to help support them and
it's friends have to help support it and
it would go broke if that didn't happen
the college lives under necessity every
human enterprise does and so our
material property rights are written in
that fact Paul Marino did I thank him
he's really great and I learned from him
every time he talks he mentioned this
essay by James Madison about property
and it's the essay is about one-half
about that kind of property but then he
also mentions in this a essay the other
kind of property we have and this is the
kind of property that makes us unique
and that is we can talk and so already
there are two things going on in this
conversation and one of the two things
that's going on is I'm telling you if I
were to talk too long today we'd all get
hungry and I don't know whether we're
gonna give you lunch or not you who are
here but the ones who are watching on TV
we're not kelly saying we are going to
give you guys lunch if you sit quietly
and the ones who are watching on TV
we're not gonna give you lunch and that
means there's a limit to what I can do
and that that means that you know my
wife loves to talk about how smart our
dogs on there are in our house cuz they
know what time five o'clock is and she
says yeah they love me so much at 4:45
you see we're just like them but the
other thing is we can laugh at that joke
we have a critical distance from these
necessities and James Madison says in
that essay that Paul quoted from he says
a very beautiful thing he says that our
property also includes the things that
are going on in our souls because
remember we could all steal stuff to get
money and now you know that was that
famous guy Willie somebody who said why
don't you brought banks and he said
because there was money in there you
know that's why not do that a dog would
and if he did it wouldn't be stealing so
something is inside us and that thing is
a divine spark and Madison recognizes
that spark you know people think of him
today that he was just interested in
little property not at all he actually
describes the property we have in our
conscience in our opinions and things
like that in our worship he says a
property of a peculiar value he says in
the opinions we have especially about
God and we have a right to those things
and those things are the things that are
the most purely our own you see because
he says of them in this essay you don't
need anything else to protect them by
the way I'm gonna stop and mention
something everything I think today that
this is true everything I'm gonna quote
from today is in our Constitution reader
and that's going to be produced pretty
soon for sale and if you apply for a
scholarship we'll give you the darn
thing
because there's about 600 pages of stuff
in it and it's gorgeous and it's the
stuff on both sides about half of the
stuff in the reader is people who didn't
like the Constitution United States
including some of those progressives
that Paul Marino quoted from and
including John Calhoun and people like
that who tried to actually John Calhoun
was a big-time unionist he wanted the
Union to stay together he just wanted
slavery to be legal everywhere in it
because he thought it was an abomination
for people of different colors to live
together as equals and then Alexander
Stephens the vice president of the
Confederacy is in it saying that the
great scientific truth has been
discovered that slavery is right because
these people are inferiors and the
founders are in it saying uniformly that
slavery is wrong and they've got to do
something about it I'll say in a minute
why that was complicated to do and you
can read all this in that reader and
this essay by Madison on property which
he wrote in 1792 it's in there and it's
about this long it's like so much that
Madison did he had a gift it was kind of
like what Lincoln had and that was he
could be a very brief and precise he's
not as poetic as Lincoln but he's
beautiful in the way he can argue and in
this essay about this long you should
get it and read it and study it
carefully even do a google search on the
internet just put Madison property 1792
and you'll find it and it's very worth
reading because he says in there that in
our necessitous lives these things that
we have the gone and our souls our
opinions and our things like that that
these are a remnant spared to us at the
end of the day to soothe our condition
in that pretty it's like reading a good
book at the end of the day and so you've
got a right to the things that you make
by your own labor because your time is
all you got and you're never gonna get
this minute to just pass back and how
you spend that time is a duty that you
have for yourselves and your loved ones
and your country and
that connects directly to the other
thing that completes the whole dimension
of the human being and that is inside
your soul there is a critical distance
from the many necessities we face and
they are our property - Madison says as
it as it is true that we have a right to
our property so it is also true that we
have a property in our rights didn't
that lovely it's one of the most
generous and fine things I have read
anybody saying in all of life and
remember Madison is a man who is busy
founding a government and he knows a lot
of history and so he knows that it
stands to reason that he's likely to
occupy some high office in that
government if it's successful and if
it's not successful he knows he's very
likely to be killed his friend Thomas
Jefferson he didn't sign the Declaration
independence Madison didn't his friend
Thomas Jefferson wrote the words and in
support of this declaration we mutually
pledge to each other Our Lives our
Fortunes and our sacred honor and there
was a warrant out for the arrest of
every one of those guys and that warrant
was issued not by a court but by the
king directly and he didn't go to a
police officer it went to general gage
and the order said go find those guys
and round them up and even if it means a
general war find him and suppress them
that had been in existence for a year
when they want those words in the
Declaration of Independence and so the
stakes were big and that meant that they
were risking their lives and so why
should they not have the reward that
goes with that and that is if we win if
we lose we're good we're dead if we win
heck we get to be the president or the
king why would we in preparation for
that and this is in 1792 after the
founders have completed the Constitution
even we have our republic now why should
they be writing all these things about
the rights of the citizens and the
restraints on the government and compare
that kind of writing to the kind of
writing that goes on today some of which
Balmerino cite
and isn't it true it's easy to see isn't
it that people in power in government
argue commonly that the government
should have more power wonder of wonders
that that would happen what's more
remarkable is that this other thing
happened why did that happen by people
who believe very much in a very strong
government and you see when they argue
that this material property to which we
have a right connects to the more sacred
he Madison says kind of property that is
more fully our own he says I've been
reading a biography of Dietrich
Bonhoeffer you should read it it's
really good metaxas is the author and
Bonhoeffer was you know he was dead by
the time he was 40 I think and I'm at
the place now where he's in prison and
it's about to turn bad for him and the
Gestapo got him right and he's part of
the plot to kill Hitler good for him and
plot didn't succeed so Hitler did it but
in prison what he's got is his thoughts
and his prayers and he was such a
powerful man because he perfected the
use of those two a very unusual spot and
so he stayed pretty happy and he was an
encouragement to everyone around him you
see even that fierce and terrible regime
could not rest out of our souls out of
his soul that thing that he owned that
made him a human being go read a man's
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl we
should put that in the Constitution
reader it's he was a very great man he
was it's about his life in a
concentration camp he survived it and he
was happy in the camp kind of miserable
and happy because the most important
thing about him couldn't be taken from
him
and the physical things we have those
things are the guardians that we erect
of our souls and our consciences just
like our body is the guardian of those
things and the point is the author of
the Constitution United States the chief
author knew that and put that in
beautiful language and set up a
government he said to protect the
combination of those things and our
government has done that more than any
government ever did it now I mention a
couple of great pieces of legislation
that have been passed pursuant to that
understanding and they too are the most
generous and beautiful of pieces of
legislation and they're available to us
as models right now we could do nothing
better than to emulate these two pieces
of legislation both of them concerned
land one of them is was passed in the
summer of 1787 by the Congress under the
Articles of Confederation it's called
the Northwest Ordinance and what it does
is along with the land ordinance from
two years earlier of 1785 it disposes of
the land in the Northwest Territory
that's the first great piece of land
that the United States owned George
Washington nationally personally
surveyed part of it and it's the first
place that we were going to bring into
the country after the new government was
established after we were having a free
government of our own it's about four
years after the American Revolution ends
and what they decide is they're gonna
come in as equal States not colonies we
never had any colonies in America until
a different principle came along and
made Franklin Teddy Roosevelt think it
wouldn't be a bad idea to have a colony
right because if there's no moral law
there's only interest you could do what
what can you not do in such a
circumstance is that so in the Northwest
Ordinance it's organized that these when
these places get settled they can
organize a free government and they can
apply and they'll come in as equal
states and in the meantime they all have
their liberties like everybody else
under the protection of the federal
government that's a little more
complicated story than I just put it but
that's the rough story
and of the land they organize that it's
going to be divided into townships each
one with 36 sections mile on a side and
these 36 townships sorry these 36
sections with one exception will be sold
into private hands to pay off the debts
of the government the point being it's a
really great thing for the public if the
land gets into private hands and gets
used now the only reservation by the way
was I can even show you where it is in
Hillsdale Michigan it's about four
hundred yards from the campus there's a
there's a one section that is reserved
for one public use only and that's for
education in each Township to be
controlled as an endowment by the states
it's by the way the greatest subsidy of
education ever given and remember the
rules
about it in total that are ever passed
because you know less than a mile from
here is the United States Department of
Education a fittingly ugly building and
and the rules that they pass are so
innumerable that I'm told by our
attorney whom we keep here in town to
prevent the federal government from
giving us any money that I you know a
reasonably educated man will be unable
to read because only an expert can read
them and all the rules in the Northwest
Ordinance regarding education
I will now quote to you from memory
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind schools and the
means of education shall ever be
encouraged short and pretty now
the land sales to pay the dead is
precisely the opposite of the policy
that we are pursuing today because it
does just so happen that the president
within the last ten days has asked the
Congress for a doubling of the budget to
purchase land because every year he says
millions of acres are being open quote
lost to development close quat now that
means by the way it's the opposite idea
isn't it
urgent and so we're gonna we're not
gonna sell the money sell the land to
pay the debt we're going to borrow money
I think you may have heard the federal
government actually has a deficit and it
hasn't been narrowing rapidly in recent
days but the point is they will borrow
money to buy land it is the direct
opposite of the policy of the founders
and and the principles behind it are the
direct opposite of the policy of the
founders that's the first law the second
law is like unto it except even better
it was signed by Abraham Lincoln in 1862
and it's one of my favorite laws ever
passed
it's the Homestead Act and the Homestead
Act provided that if you would live on
it for five years and work it and if
your name was anything up to and
including Methuselah or Bartholomew
those of you could be anybody you could
be called anything you could have 160
acres of ground and they gave away 10
percent of the land area of the United
States has existed then to people that
they didn't know and who were never
going to be able to vote for anybody
than sitting in Congress and about 1.6
million families got land under that
thing now that law it's a very long law
you know by the standards of that day so
I'm by Lincoln as I say I counted it up
this morning every time I counted I get
a different number if we can assume
maybe there's some finding edited
versions of it on the internet but the
latest number I
it's 1370 words long that is to say it
is the length of a long newspaper
article and it achieves the disposition
of 10% of the land area of the United
States as it then existed into private
hands no money coming into the federal
treasury it is a different idea about
property rights that's driving that
thing and I think that's a model because
by the way if you have a lot of Dan it
just only two ways my father made me get
an undergraduate minor in accounting
it's a very he made me learn to type too
my dad was a great guy and I didn't want
to do either one of those things and he
made me do it and I benefit from it to
this very day both of them but I can
tell you that it's just a simple
accounting fact that if you have a lot
of debt there are only two ways to pay
apart from declaring bankruptcy which
would be complicated for the United
States devastating for the United States
and to the world and to all of us one is
you can pay it out of income and the
other is you could sell assets Japan we
have that sense I don't even know what
they're worth
but we're not selling them to pay debt
the way we did the Revolutionary War
debt
we're buying more we're borrowing
against future income to buy more assets
it by the way being true in our country
that the overwhelming majority of it has
nothing on it and never will by the way
I mean unless some incredible change
happens and there's no such insight so
it's not interesting that they do that
but going along with that because
remember the point that Madison said
that these two things are connected
these two kinds of property and that any
government that didn't protect the
second kind the holy the sacred the
elevated kind
would be blameable even if protected the
first time kind but he also says that
the two things stand on exactly the same
justification and so if you're gonna
have your property rights in the narrow
sense you're going to have your right to
freedom of speech and worship and those
are the most sacred kinds of rights and
sure enough today we hear it said in the
middle of a presidential campaign that
it's the purpose of the government to
spread the wealth around and there is an
aforementioned astonishing officer in
the government today Paul Marino named
his name his name is Cass Sunstein and
he is I can't remember the bureaucratic
name office of something in something in
something yeah they're by the way don't
they all have the same name
he's the regulatory czar and we have
officials called czars in America now
and we popularly refer to them and the
administration and it's not just this
administration goodness there was one in
the Reagan administration
they don't repudiate the name and I'm
supposed to mention things we should do
to get back our economic you know to
protect them better well the first thing
we should do is that we should mount a
national campaign to get use of rid of
the use of the terms are this
particulars ardham by the way was
created in the last few days I I can
remember the day because I looked it up
just the other day on December the 11th
1980 that is you know 30 so 40 days
before Ronald Reagan was sworn in as
president the Congress passed and
President Carter signed the paperwork
reduction Act and we've all heard of
that right because you get in an
envelope every time you get something
from the government it's got an extra
slip of paper in it
and you know nobody gets the joke it
leaves nobody in this town and and the
paperwork reduction Act requires a bunch
of things and one of the things that
requires is before you submit a form
that the American people have to fill
out you have to submit a form to the
Office of Management and Budget and get
permission to do that first form it's
very good this it's not quite as good
it's Paul Marino's description of the
Commission I'll return to that in just a
second but it's almost as good and and
in the paperwork reduction Act they
created an office and Cass Sunstein
occupies that office now in other words
in an anti bureaucratic it was supposed
to be bureaucratic office created in the
waive coincident in time at least with
the wave that brought Ronald Reagan into
power the guy who holds the job now is
called czar and he is a candid proponent
of the idea of the allocation of rights
to speak because you know I'm talking
just probably come to his notice how up
so probably I'm talking to several
thousand people right now if I haven't
driven them off yet and it's close
enough to lunchtime then maybe someone
will start leaving
that's a lot of people and I'm a little
guy from Arkansas and I run this private
college and I'm making you know nasty
arguments right now I'm said anything
nasty but these are serious things right
why should I be allowed to do that
Dietrich Bonhoeffer was a brilliant
preacher and he got good at putting
asides in his sermons to the Gestapo
officers who were typically in church to
hear and the Reich's
Church it became and there was a Nazi
official who was appointed to watch over
it to make sure that it comported in all
of its operations with the public good
Madison says about the constitutional
protections what is government with the
profoundest of all commentaries on human
nature if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither internal or external
controls on the government would be
needed Madison also says that if the
government I'll read this bit to you
excuse me I'll have to find it so I'm
gonna read it to you for Batum it's
pretty good
he says about in this essay on property
he says about regulation that is not a
just government nor is property secured
under it where arbitrary restrictions
exemptions and monopolies denied a part
of its citizens that free use of their
faculties faculties you know that means
nut it doesn't just mean that doesn't
mean your barn that means your right to
pray that's what that means exemptions
and monopolies about that what did the
king dislike why did he issue his writ
against the revolutionaries they were
writing stuff he didn't like they had to
stop
and free choice of their occupations
which not only constitute their property
in the general sense of the word but are
the means of acquiring property strictly
so-called so regulation can be a danger
to both kinds of property he says and
remember he'd risk his life fighting a
tyranny he knew taxation a just security
of property is not afforded by that
government under which unequal taxes
oppress one species of property and
reward another species where arbitrary
taxes invade the domestic sanctuaries of
the rich and excessive taxes grind the
faces of the poor so you know what it
requires to have representative
government you know what a revolutionary
thing that is we take it for granted now
ours is the first ever in human history
Madison says that is purely
representative you can't have that
unless there are two things and separate
and one of those two things is a
government and the other of those two
things is a society that is big enough
and vibrant enough and independent
enough to be placed in control of the
government and by the miracle of
representation they write in the
Federalist Papers the rest of us are
liberated from the daily cares of
government to pursue our lives and take
care of our families which means to get
practice at being a self-governing and
free individual but on the other hand
the government operates in control of us
and if the government becomes so large
or intrusive as to upset those
arrangements and the violations of
property are a sign that that is
happening then of course you won't have
that gift anymore and the character of
everyone in the country will be affected
by that by that fact
now finished with what we do I could do
it real fast long time ago in Southern
California I got into a quarrel with
something called the South Coast Air
Quality Management District and I
discovered that I got mad because I
criticized them they attack me that's at
all these guys like to fight and I don't
go before them to get permits because
the other thing I was releasing in the
way of pollution was hot air they didn't
have the power to stop that yet and I
discovered that they had a beautiful
building it's still there if you go look
and see where the 57 and the 90 freeways
come together in Southern California you
can see it's up on a hill it's really
gorgeous and they got all their money
from fees and fines on the regulated
community and they levied the fees and
fines and they heard all the claims just
like Paul said they were the executive
judicial and legislative branches all
rolled into one and that got changed
because somebody made a stink about it
and I believe by the way that these
arguments by James Madison are beautiful
and true and I believe that they require
only to be made to be victorious now I'm
in the college business and so to me you
know if you're a carpenter everything
looks like a nail if you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail to me
everything looks like a teaching
opportunity and first you got to learn
but then you got to argue because the
American Revolution is a very coherent
thing and it is the greatest thing of
its kind ever to happen and every one of
us in this room and every one of us
listening has enjoyed the benefits of
that revolution and owes something
because of it and so we should learn to
argue because the two forms of rule are
before us and we're going to pick one of
them pretty soon and all we got to do is
make the right arguments and leave the
rest in the hands of God thank you
thank you for those comments doctor on
the first question is actually from
Trisha from Madison Mississippi and she
asks can you give a definition of the
pursuit of happiness and tell us what
the Founding Fathers actually meant by
it and does it mean the same thing as
property that's great so well I wonder
who that person is whoever that is
you're admitted the reason you might ask
if it's the same thing as property is
because in the Virginia bill of rights
for example passed a few days before the
the Declaration of Independence they
mentioned property in that place where
they have pursuit of happiness in the
Declaration and that gives rise
sometimes to the argument that by
pursuit of happiness they mean happiness
is a relative term and there is no real
definition of it and that's foolishness
because first of all happiness occurs
again in the Declaration of Independence
about three lines down where it says
people have the natural right to throw
off an oppressive government and set up
a new government which seems to them
most likely to secure their safety and
happiness so happiness is a thing you
could secure and the classical teaching
and this is very well known to the
founders and it's also their teaching
it's in that quote that I used at the
beginning from Washington in the first
inaugural address in two soluble Union
between between the virtue and happiness
happiness is a human being doing well
and that means the human being living
well doing the right thing now you can't
have an entitlement to the government to
that because you got to do a bunch of
stuff you know some people some people
are miserable when they're rich and at
peace and comfortable and some people
think that the greatest experience they
ever went through and the thing that was
defining and elevating thing in their
lives was to spend four years in a
German concentration camp right what is
their qualities of soul that are
different in one person to the next and
it is our business to develop our
qualities of soul as best
we can and I just had one more point to
that because the constitutional scheme
of America Madison says is devised he
says in the 49th Federalist to place our
reason in control of the government and
to have our passions be controlled by it
and that is by the way the exact and
precise classical definition of the
proper ordering of the soul and of
course if it takes time to get something
done in the government if there's more
than one step and if we can't just act
immediately but only through
representatives and if there's two
houses of Congress and there's three
branches of government and there's
federalism it's all kind of complicated
and it means the stuff that gets done
will be tend to be stuff that's
sustained over time in other words more
reasonable stuff and not just the flight
of fancy at the moment and so happiness
requires the right to property for the
reasons I've been explaining and
includes the right to property and is a
more comprehensive term I'm Brittany
Baldwin and I'm from Houston Texas and
along those lines if we understand that
happiness requires the right to property
and how do we as civil society rekindle
capitalism with a conscience in a
postmodern culture that largely rejects
morality especially of a classical and
Christian nature that's good
I could if this if we were at Hillsdale
College right now I would actually make
Brittany answer that question
and she could isn't the point though
that there are two points one is look
about you
the only trim that's bad is that things
are coming to a head
you know and that's not because of
anything anybody did right now it's just
that we've been spending so much money
for so long that now we're about to go
broke but the counter trends that are
emerging are very good there's a lot of
people you know the American people have
taken to the streets to demand that the
government not give them so much stuff
that's pretty good so first of all I
think there's kind of a resurgence in
understanding of the importance of
property rights now about the moral
stuff there's a lot of confusion about
that because we live in the age of
relativism and we live in an age shaped
by those doctrines that Paul Marino
described where we think that you can't
know anything that your opinions are
only the product of your circumstances
right Frank good now one of the
progressives founder of the American
Political Science Association for
goodness sake he write he was a teacher
all his life and he writes once we
teachers perhaps take ourselves too
seriously because he said what they
really will come to believe is just
whatever put on them by their economic
circumstances I can't know anything
right well one of the reasons why that
opinion is not universally held is it's
stupid and why is it stupid it's stupid
because if it were true how could he
know that thing he just said what's the
use of even that opinion right and of
course none of us can act for five
minutes like we know stuff one of
Lincoln's favorite examples the Lincoln
was happy the state by the way it's a
important fact and in the history of
statesmanship that Winston Churchill
loved pigs and and Abraham Lincoln
constantly use them as an example and
their hogs are very handy things right
because all of us are human in this room
and all everybody watching except maybe
my dogs at home are human and the dogs
are they they're too stupid know what
I'm saying even when I'm there with
right but and we all look all different
right everybody in the room I can you
can't see the people in the room but
some of them are you know like there's
women in here and they look you know
more attractive than the men as a rule
and so we're not equal right somebody
bring a pig in here and then all of a
sudden we all look really equal you know
cuz we're not that what's that hog doing
in here
that's what the meaning of human
equality means but by the way morality
is born in that obvious ability to
perceive if if somebody brought a pony
in here that's more plausible and we
need to get it out right we might put a
halter on the pony or even a bit in his
mouth and lead him out and nobody'd
think anything about it much but if one
of these kids from Hillsdale College
over there was being bad and I put a bit
in her mouth you know first of all
Britney stuff she'd probably kick me but
but everybody would think wait that's
wrong what does he think she is a horse
it's wrong to treat her like a horse can
that knowledge ever be a faced in the
last serious letter he wrote in his life
at Thomas Jefferson says about the
Decker instead of Penniston it means
that some men are not born with saddles
on their backs nor others booted and
spurred to ride them by the grace of God
you see the point moral knowledge is
complicated and difficult to get it is
not and that means that despite the fact
that there are generations of
laminations upon our common sense by
academic theories common sense has an
irresistible way of breaking through and
sophisticated people like Professor
Marino are capable of sophisticated
defenses of common sense and you put
those two things together and you get
something good
it's just another op Russian bread from
Rialto California ass is economic
liberty same thing as accurate that's
good keep thinking these questions are
planted but I think they're not that's
Katie Batchelder and her parents are
here she wouldn't tell a fib in front of
them it's too good a question but here's
the point the point is a sophisticated
thing happens by Franklin Roosevelt and
the Commonwealth address did Paul talk
about this did you you talked about that
didn't you well I'll mention it again
simple what do you figured out was its
hack to overturn the American Revolution
if you have to be against the
Constitution and the Declaration at the
same time because one of them's pretty
and one of them's awkward the
Constitution is in the way it's very
pretty if you understand it but the
Declaration dependence is mighty
beautiful and so what Roosevelt sets out
to do is to convert the Declaration and
its defense of property rights into an
empowerment of the government to take
control of your property to make sure
nobody loses his property and the point
is that's the point of contest right
does it mean that well first of all the
declaration independence does not mean
that to the people who wrote it and
that's the clearest thing in the world
can it be made under a fair construction
to mean that here's the reasoning points
you have to go through it would be cool
and you know by the way there was always
welfare in America always and there
should be welfare today it should be
local because that way it can be close
to the thing that it's dealing with and
it won't necessarily then have to be
like this national great entitlement
which has certainly had some Association
in America with the decline of the
family and the growth of illegitimate
birth and so local policy is better at
things like that and if you concentrate
and here's the real reasoning point if
you actually set up a government in
which everyone's property in principle
is at the command of the state to help
whomever it wants
then limited-government is gone and the
reason that's a bad thing is because the
people in the government happened not to
be angels anymore than us outside the
government and so the best plan because
by the way we've got a record about that
plan now their problems with it you know
the welfare state has not been good in
all respects right
and so another plan would be like the
greatest economic improvement plan in
the history of the United States in the
history of the world and that is the
Constitution the United States look what
happened to America in the 19th century
did pretty good and you know by the way
what's happening in China that is
happening because they emulate us when
they do and it is limited only when they
fail to emulate us which in important
respects they do fail and by the way
there's a whole bunch of people
including a senior official in the Bush
administration the Secretary of
Education Margaret Spellings who said
that we had to emulate China what she
didn't like she knew that's not fair let
me be fair to her she said that we have
to have a national system of standards
in education in order to be able to
compete with China and my response to
that was when I become more like them
they're trying to become more like us so
yeah the answer is if economic security
means that the government is the
guarantor well after the government pays
back 14 trillion dollars then it will be
broke
hi dr. iron Dave Hatcher from Falls
Church Virginia and the proud parent of
a Hillsdale graduate we agree ideas have
consequences we agree that elections
have consequences as your friend Rush
Limbaugh likes to say we are in the
arena for the Battle of ideas let me ask
an absurd question how do you think is
the best way to allow Hillsdale College
Grove City College Claremont Institute
and others to turnout the thousands and
thousands of economics professors to get
them into the other universities and
colleges in this country
well thousands and thousands is too many
but you know because the principle is
one riot one Ranger things have a magic
about them you know I he mentioned the
Claremont Institute you know the guy who
does Constitution stuff at the Heritage
Foundation across the street from where
we stand most of the people I do that do
declare who've had a lot to say about
the Constitution and recovering the
Founding are people who got education
together a long time ago I'm one of them
Paul over there his his teacher Hermann
belts was a friend of my teacher Harry
Jaffa and we're both more ignorant than
our teachers but we picked up a bit so
the power of Education is a very great
power and it was the progressives by the
way who used it for power that's not the
deal like I you know these kids in here
the ones you've seen on TV and the one
can see them now what do they like I can
tell you what they like I work with them
all the time you can't make them into
anything what you can do is have a bunch
of arguments with them and let them go
through the arguments for real that
means if you want to understand what's
wrong with America today you're going to
have to make a choice between Woodrow
Wilson and James Madison and you can't
make that choice if you don't read both
of them and read them in a fair light
and understand how to make the argument
for them the ones I don't agree with
with that as much as for the ones I do
agree with and that can be very powerful
because you know what Cass Sunstein
believes everybody believes that today
in the academic world and those of us
who don't believe that we're outnumbered
but we've got a key advantage we go
around making sense all the time and
it's possible it's possible that that's
because we run up against a lot of
argument so about that the education
business works the way it works and you
know in Hillsdale we've just started a
graduate school and there will be some
PhDs coming out of that starting the
first ones will arrive in a year in a
bit from now in the fall of 2012 and
they're going to go through a very
rigorous and difficult life and some of
them aren't gonna make it and they're
not gonna just sit and listen to
doctrines from us they're gonna get
educated the way we did and they'll get
good at it after they do it for about 25
years and that'll make a difference as
time goes on but I will tell you that's
one part important part of the solution
but the second important part of the
solution is anybody can think anybody
can think and spend some time at it you
know the people who are watching this
there are thousands of them thank you
they're thinking that's very powerful
and that's happening right now this
morning from Hillsdale yes
dr. Arne talked about the Northwest
Ordinance and the Homestead Act these
seem like government intervention in the
economy does this mean some intervention
is justified so that's doubtless iliad
geysers and so I have to give a private
answer and then the real answer the
private answer is shut up Elliot get
back to work the yeah the answer is of
course some intervention in the economy
is justified and necessary the question
is what is the end and what is the scope
of the intervention and so
that particular intervention those were
transfers of wealth one of a pure
transfer of wealth from the public to
the private sector and the other was a
sale - they really just transfer debts
for assets that's what they were doing
but both of them and you know the
government has to tax and see remember
about this everybody should remember
this you know there's two simple things
one is states don't have rights people
do States are crucial to the defense of
our rights and we need to repeal the
17th amendment it would be just such a
good thing if we did but the federal
government is supposed to be a very
powerful government and we need it to be
because first of all states were messing
with people's rights that's why they
called the Constitutional Convention but
second wait you know why Wayne County
where the Detroit Airport is close to us
is called Wayne County because general
mad Anthony Wayne who was a very brave
guy was sent up there by George
Washington to deal with some Indians and
stuff and what was peered at him across
the river on our side of the river was a
bunch of British troops who were
operating on American soil with impunity
and we weren't strong enough to do
anything about that and that means that
you know there's just a lot of bad
countries in the world and they might
hurt us and that's why if you read
article 1 section 8 about half of the
powers have to do with National Defense
the others have to do with the National
system of Commerce and three of them
have to do with the federal government
controlling the property on which it
operates and stuff like that
so the point is of course there have to
be things like that but their purpose
should be a liberal Society with
representative government that can be
strong and effective and not get out of
hand that's what you got to be after and
those things by the way those two things
were because because another thing is
you know education is very important
every American founder that I can think
of I Paul will tell me if I'm wrong
about this I think every single one of
them was in favor of some kind of
universal education
and so was Abraham Lincoln everybody
thinks that welfare for the very needy
and people have misfortunes is a good
idea but everybody thought stuff like
that should be done locally where people
can get practice at doing things like
that and share in the running of the
government it's just a lot more
efficient and you know Hillsdale College
for 167 years has been in has been
performing an important public service
the articles of the college say that
that's what we did but we don't but
that's a private organization doing that
for the benefit of the public and if
you're trying to sustain a society like
that then you won't make rules at the
top complex and remote empowering
distant officials in their countless
numbers I mean and I mean that literally
nobody knows how many there are
nor can you keep count day to day that
is not the way that is the wrong kind
the Homestead Act is the right kind John
Dewey makes a distinction to formal and
negative Liberty and effectively if I
have the freedom and liberty to ride a
bicycle but I don't have a bicycle
doesn't that make my Liberty ineffective
and shouldn't the government give me a
bicycle
I like bicycles yeah hey free bicycle
yeah the point is right but the bicycle
is not free and see Madison says in that
essay we've been talking about all
morning everybody should go read that
thing it's too great he says that in the
larger sense a property right is a is
anything to which a person may attach a
value and have a right leaving the light
advantage to everyone else now I'll tell
you what that distinction does if you
pass a law that everybody gets a bicycle
if they want one all you've really done
is passed a law that says that
everybody's got to buy a bicycle and
that means that the people who don't
want a bicycle they've got to have one
too Franklin Roosevelt says in one of
his most important speeches that a
farmer should have a guaranteed minimum
price for his crops so let's say he
decides to grow it was my favorite
example nobody else finds it funny but I
found it funnier for 20 years let's say
he decides to grow Mexican jumping beans
I don't even know if there are such
things but but let's say he decides to
grow that and nobody wants some they got
to buy him anyway right but then the
next step of course is the farmers going
to be told what to buy so everybody can
worship all at the same time and nobody
takes anything from anybody
everybody can pray all at the same time
and nobody takes anything from anybody
everybody can talk all at the same time
and although it's annoying we can
survive that right everybody can enjoy
their property that is to say the things
they have earned or have been given to
them by their rightful owners and
everybody can have all of that there is
and they don't have to take anything
from anybody but if positive rights in
the sense that Duty means
Isaiah Berlin once made this big
argument following him to if positive
rights come then what it does is it sets
up
conflict in the society because then
government is about who gets what from
home and so the justice and generosity
and freedom of the constitutional
arrangements breed harmony and peace in
the society and that principle breeds
class warfare